‏the idea of mindate of body body and
mind con
in and lot of we as muslims especially
and say
this with all the respect is that we
have become people who expect
it a
def i need
‏somebody give up something because i
need somebody cous to you
resp gracious to you be
resp not
[Silence]
‏mind take
‏first you don't know
take الله الله
سهال اللهد
‏that incles
spes our parents and
friends use blessings
wisely if are for was
as know the value or does not appreciate
three things until
they
right and part of it is the time that
you have to the he
given so
منعل
[Silence]
الحد لله رب العالم ربنا اتنا في الدنيا
حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب النار
وقنا عذاب القبر وقنا عذاب جهنم وقنا شر
فتنه المحيا الممات وقنا شت المسيح الدجال
ربنا تقبل مننا السميع العليم وتب علينا
يا مواب الرحيم وصلى الله على محمد وعلى
اله وصحبه اجمين برحمتك الراحمين اللهم
امين اللهم امينك
[Silence]
لامكم
545 545
استووا
اعتدلوا
استووا الله
اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
والله يدعو الى دار
السلام ويهدي من
يشاء الى صراط
مستقيم للذين احسنوا الحسنى وزياده ولا
يرهق وجوههم قتر ولا ذله اولئك اصحاب
الجنه هم فيها
خالدون والذين كسبوا سيئات جزاء
سيئه بمثلها وترهقهم ذله ما لهم من الله
من عاصم
كانما اغشيت وجوههم قطعا من الليل مظلما
اولئك اصحاب النار هم فيها
خالدون ويوم نحشرهم جميعا ثم نقول للذين
اشركوا مكانكم انتم
وشركاؤكم فزيلنا بينهم وقال
شركاؤهم ما كنتم ايانا
تعبدون فكفى بالله شهيدا بيننا وبينكم ان
كنا عن عبادتكم
لغافلين هنالك تبلو كل نفس ما اسلفت وردوا
الى الله مولاهم الحق وضل عنهم ما كانوا
يفترون قل من
يرزقكم من السماء والارض امن يملك السمع
والابصار ومن يخرج الحي من الميت ويخرج
الميت من الحي ومن يدبر
الامر فسيقولون الله
فقل افلا
تتقون فذلكم الله ربكم
الحق فماذا بعد الحق الا
الضلال فانا
تصرفون كذلك حقت كلمه ربك على الذين فسقوا
انهم لا
يؤمنون قل هل من
شركائكم من يبدا الخلق ثم
يعيده قل الله يبدا الخلق ثم يعيده فان
تؤفكون قل هل من
شركائكم من يهدي الى
الحق قل الله يهدي
للحق افمن يهدي الى الحق احق ان يتبع امن
لا يهدي الا ان يهد
فما لكم كيف
تحكمون وما يتبع اكثرهم الا
ظنا ان الظن لا يغني من الحق شيئا ان الله
عليم بما
يفعلون وما كان هذا القران ان يفترى من
دون الله ولكن تصديق الذي بين يديه وتفصيل
الكتاب لا ريب فيه من رب
العالمين ام يقولون
افتراه قل فاتوا
بسوره مثله وادعوا من استطعتم من دون الله
ان كنتم
صادقين بل كذبوا بما لم يحيطوا بعلمه ولما
ياتهم تاوي
كذلك كذب الذين من قبلهم فانظر كيف كان
عاقبه
الظالمين ومنهم من يؤمن به ومنهم من لا
يؤمن به وربك اعلم بالمفسدين
وان كذبوك فقل لي عملي ولكم عملكم انتم
بريئون من ما اعمل وانا
بريء مما
تعملون ومنهم من يستمعون
اليك افانت تسمع الصم ولو كانوا لا
يعقلون ومنهم من ينظر اليك افانت تهدي
العمي ولو كانوا لا
يبصرون ان الله لا يظل الناس شيئا ولكن
الناس انفسهم
يظلمون ويوم يحشرهم كان لم يلبثوا الا
ساعه من النهار يتعارفون بينهم قد خسر
الذين كذبوا بلقاء الله وما كانوا
مهتدين واما نرينك بعض الذي نعدهم او
نتوفينك
فالينا
مرجعهم فالينا مرجعهم ثم الله شهيد عه ولا
يستقدمه بياتا او نهارا ماذا يستعجل منه
المجرمون ثم اذا ما وقع امنتم
تستعجلون
ل احق
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
ال الحمد لله